[Music]
the story is very important if you look
at the actual structure of a story it's
been used for thousands of years for
cultures to pass on their morals and
their lore in their values even
preliterate generations could pass those
on and they'd stay fully intact so the
powerful thing about story is it
demonstrates transformation and humans
are hard-wired to enjoy observing
transformation we've got the four
seasons we've got stories that are told
that show transformation we're hardwired
to enjoy it what happens is when someone
tells a story specifically a story of
transformation were connected
heart-to-heart and those stories because
of its inherent structure are easily
repeated and passed along it's not very
often you can think of other last
presentation I can practically repeat
and stays intact it just doesn't happen
but it does happen with story so we need
to use this as a tool to make sure that
our stories are passed on and people
have a way to spread our ideas through
story
[Music]
great stories will resonate with an
audience and when you're sitting and
listening to a really great story your
physical bodies is reacting to it you
don't even realize it you can get a
chill down your spine your heart may
race your eyes actually dilate so you
can take more in the power of a great
story is how it connects us how it makes
us feel it's also how in that connection
as we root for that hero to get over
their roadblocks and emerge transformed
we are changed in the process so story
isn't just about observing change it's
about applying the learnings from that
story to our own self to make sure that
we too are transformed in some way
through the power of story sometimes as
a leader we're supposed to be the one
that's strong we're supposed to be the
one they're keeping it all together and
it's a struggle to be so authentic and
so transparent to tell personal stories
people are like well I'm here at work to
get my job done I'm not here to get
emotional or I'm not here to you know
I've got a whole lot of other things
instead of that and I contend that that
you would be a better leader should you
stop and have these very human moments
these very human connections right it's
like ants right they come together they
go do it and then they know where to go
and they just keep going in those kinds
of moments that you do where you connect
deeply with these people not only builds
people's loyalties to you it builds them
to the brand but the interesting thing
is they align more quickly and you get
so much more done doing these little
moments of emotional connection and
using story to make those moments of
connection makes it even more powerful
and keeps the organization healthy and
strengthens you as a leader
I define happiness as contentment in the
moments that I'm most content are when
I'm connecting deeply and personally
with other people so spending time with
people that I really love and admire and
people who get me makes me super happy
you